dc comics has confirmed that superman is
officially a little light in the loafers
i myself had always had my suspicions
the tights the chiseled body the lack if
we're honest of any real sexual tension
with lois lane but the creatives have
now dispelled any doubts the new
superman much like our entire culture is
super
duper gay i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from gman who says
before exploring space
maybe kamala should explore the southern
border and see it with her own eyes yes
that's true maybe a little less
cringe-inducing performance with the
child actors about the wonders of outer
space from the vice president s and a
little more doing her job when
for instance she's tasked with the
southern border which practically
speaking no longer exists the sort of
problems that keep one up at night it's
hard to get a good night's sleep with
all of this madness in our country one
way to help ensure you get a good
night's sleep
bowling brand sheets i have had the
privilege of staying at nice hotels this
is the only silver lining to having to
be on the road and away from my
beautiful wife and young baby is
occasionally they'll they'll take me out
of the flea bags they'll put me up at a
nice hotel and the first thing you
notice is the quality of the bedding the
quality of the sheets and i didn't i
didn't know this
for my bachelor dumb but
you can get the luxury five-star quality
bedding that you get at a top hotel you
can get that every single night in your
home and you can do that with bowl and
branch bowl and branch has these
incredible sheets signature hem sheets
100 organic cotton
they start out soft they get softer and
softer and nicer and nicer over time
they've got a wonderful satin weave
there's no middleman between you and
bowling branch so you get luxury quality
for the fairest price 30 night
worry-free guarantee but you're going to
love it so you're not going to worry
about that 30 39 guarantee to experience
an entirely new standard of comfort
visit bowlingbranch.com get 15 off your
first set of sheets with promo code
michael that's b-o-l-l and branch com
promo code michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l
superman
is pretty
and witty
and now
he is gay
i do not follow the superhero stuff all
that closely you know i i never really
read comic books as a kid and i
certainly don't read them now but
according to dc comics
john kent who is
the new superman he's the
son of clark kent and lois lane the
original superman and his beard
john kent is apparently bisexual this is
a very important plot point of course
for the man of steel
uh
he also in this new comic will have a
love scene with a dude and the dude has
pinkish purple hair and looks a bit
bit on the young side uh and they they
have a gay kiss but he's not he's not
totally gay he's just like a little bit
gay
and it just seems to me
well i had the same reaction that blake
masters did blake masters is a
republican senate candidate in arizona
he saw the news and i don't know if he's
a comic book fan or anything but he just
he retweeted it and he said
not
everything has to be gay
there's no no offense to
people with unusual sexual desires or
behaviors or anything like that but
why does everything why is everything
gay
you know especially when june rolls
around june in our liberal liturgical
calendar is is pride month and for the
month of june at least in the west not
you know you'll notice not in the middle
east or some other places but in the
west every corporation every institution
every non-profit every person becomes
gay for exactly 30 days and then it
stops and you just think well
why
why is that
so blake masters says not everything
needs to be gay but in a way everything
sort of does need to be gay
because
if you're going to
in insist upon this new moral standard
it's not going to stop
at
do whatever you do you
you do you i'll do me
you follow your lights but don't impose
your views on anyone that's kind of the
the libertarian-ish approach someone
said libertine approach to moral
philosophy but
it doesn't really stop there because and
every single society has to have some
vision of what it considers to be the
good it's got to have some standard this
is the thesis of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds and
so as standards start to change they're
going to change for all of society and
ever i don't mean to call out just the
lgbt issue here but this is true of any
sort of standard it is going to pervade
the society and if you think that you
can just compartmentalize it and put it
in one corner of society you can't
you're trying for something that that
never has been and never will be
and you see this this shifting very
often uh
opportunistic sort of standard beyond
the realm of
of
comic book sexual politics
and into the realm of sports john gruden
who i'm reliably informed as the head
coach or was the head coach of the las
vegas raiders i'm i'm about as much of a
raiders fan as i am a fan of
the superman comic books but john gruden
was the head coach and he just resigned
he resigned under pressure he had to
resign because
decade old or even more than a decade
old emails
personal emails were leaked and in those
emails he sometimes said politically
incorrect things
notably calling the commissioner of at
the nfl
a i'll clean up the language a little
bit a wuss
a clueless wuss which every single
person knows that he is even i know that
i don't follow football at all and even
i know that roger goodell is a clueless
wuss okay and so this football coach
puts that in his emails private emails
they are leaked a decade or more later
now he has to resign and he said other
things and he made
insensitive comments and now he's got to
got to resign
what this
is i think
is bigger than just
cancel culture or saying that people
should have their their private emails
protected you know i think the angle
that most conservatives are focusing on
with the john gruden story is that
liberal democracy requires there to be a
distinction between the public and the
private sphere and then in the 1970s the
second wave feminists came in and said
the personal is political and all your
private stuff is actually public now and
we're going to scrutinize all of it and
we're going to hold you to account for
things you say at home or who does the
dishes or or what have you
there's an aspect of that sure but this
goes a little bit further and and well
people are focusing on this comment in
one of the emails where he commented on
a black player's large lips and they're
saying that he's basically you know
david duke because he he made some
racially insensitive comment i think the
more telling comments are about
sexuality and masculinity where he calls
goodell a big wuss
what we're seeing here is a
cultural revolution one that is aimed
specifically
at anti-masculinity
and we're seeing this paired up with a
technological
revolution which is namely the
surveillance revolution so to bring that
back down to earth what we're seeing is
standards changing completely on
sexuality and so
beyond
you know your sexual desires or your
sexual partners it's even it's even down
to what a man is or what a woman is it's
even down to this idea now that
masculinity is toxic in the old standard
masculinity was good the word virtue
itself is related to the word for man
right and so there was something good at
john wayne gary cooper i i'm reminded of
tony soprano a line that would come
we've been talking about tony soprano
recently because it was columbus day and
one one of the lines from that show that
keeps coming up is what have happened to
men like gary cooper what do you know
whatever happened to john wayne whatever
happened to the father knows best the
strong man now when we look at at male
figures in the culture they're all a
bunch of bumbling idiots right it's
homer simpson or ray romano and they
can't do anything and they're they're
just a big joke and their their wife has
to do everything and take care of them
because these guys can barely put their
their pants on in the morning so there's
an attack on masculinity and a lot of
what's in these emails these john gruden
emails
is locker room talk i know it's a an
overused expression these days and it's
expression that that really
hit the mainstream when donald trump was
caught on a secret tape also let's not
forget on a hot mic on a secret tape
that had been held for years and years
saying that when you're a celebrity
women let you do whatever you want you
can grab them by the you-know-what
you can grab them by the roger goodell
and
at the time a bunch of pearl clutches
said oh my gosh donald trump is openly
advocating for rape first of all he's
not talking about sexual assault at all
he said they let you do it so even even
within the context of his joke he wasn't
joking about that but second of all he
wasn't being serious he was joking
around he was having a little locker
room talk a little rough talk which is
the way that men
sometimes speak and when i say sometimes
i mean all men at some point have talked
like this and it it doesn't mean
anything it doesn't mean that you're
hateful doesn't mean that you're bigoted
it doesn't mean that if john gruden is
calling uh what's his name roger goodell
a clueless wuss doesn't mean that he
harbors a deep-seated hatred of
homosexuals or if he makes fun of some
guy's lips it doesn't mean he hates
black people it does it just means he's
talking a little bit rough and a little
offensively and a little aggressively
which is something that we used to
expect from football players and
football coaches
all right these these are people
football players who
who get involved in dog fighting rings
remember that these are people who get
involved in really tough they're
disproportionately likely to commit
crimes you can be arrested i mean there
are actually some really bad crimes that
football players have committed in
recent years but some of them have
beaten their wives and girlfriends some
of them have committed murder but the
one that we're all supposed to lose our
our collective sense over is because
this guy used some harsh language
in emails
why do we even know about the harsh
language because of the technological
aspect the surveillance state why do we
know about donald trump's joke to billy
bush on the access hollywood show
because of the surveillance state
it's become more and more and more so
anything you've ever said
in your email in your texts in your
private messages and certainly anything
you've ever tweeted
anything you've ever searched for
basically anything you've ever thought
anything you've ever said you know how
you talk and then all of a sudden you're
getting ads on your cell phone for
things that you were just talking about
in a normal conversation to someone in
real life
these things are all
pairing up and because the people who
have control because the ruling class
are the ones pushing for this cultural
revolution the asymmetries of power here
are very very concerning because people
who
descend from the political orthodoxy of
the culture are increasingly going to
have their private emails leaked and the
private conversations leaked and the
worst things they've ever said and done
are going to be broadcast and used to
ruin their lives and then people who go
along with the leftist orthodoxy are
going to have even the worst crimes that
they can commit excused
speaking of gender roles
new announcement from british airways
british airways has informed pilots and
the cabin crew
that they need to stop the hateful
language the hate speech
that passengers so often encounter on
their airplanes do you know what hate
speech i'm talking about
three words
ladies
and gentlemen
so when you get on a british airways
flight let's say i i don't know i can't
i keep really blowing my british accents
these days but i don't know something to
the effect of well hello there governor
ladies and gentlemen welcome on to the
flight yeah yeah i don't know i assume
that's i haven't flown british airways
but they will it's very nice very
civilized to say hello welcome ladies
and gentlemen welcome to your flight uh
please buckle your seatbelt we'll be
serving drinks very shortly well you're
not allowed to say that anymore and this
is because they want to promote quote
diversity and inclusion
according to the telegraph the
announcement came over the past few
weeks
and the pilots and the cabin crews were
told to use gender neutral language now
i don't what gender-neutral language are
they going to use you're not you're no
longer a lady or a gentleman presumably
you can't be called a man or a woman
what are you going to be called meat bag
hey
hey
meat bag hey flesh
flesh sack
hey what i don't know because you're the
the things that distinguish you that
seem to elevate you above the animals
that you're a lady that you're a
gentleman at least that you're a man or
a woman
those are no longer acceptable hey
person well son though son is sexist
paper
per daughter
hey per daughter is that what you're
going to be called i don't think so
in a way british airways is right to do
this
because we are no longer a society of
ladies and gentlemen we are increasingly
a barbaric society where we
don't forget the word barbarism just
comes from this idea of foreigners
speaking a language that you don't
understand and they all sound like
they're saying
that's actually where the word comes
from and increasingly that's what
our society feels like to us people are
saying things that don't mean anything
we don't speak a common language we
don't view ourselves and the world in
the same way and i'm reminded of edmund
burke you know edmund burke has that
famous line and the reflections on the
revolution in france he says the age of
chivalry is gone that of sophisters
economists and calculators has succeeded
it and the glory of europe is
extinguished forever and he's he talks
specifically about how no more will we
have that
duty that sense of loyalty that proud
submission
of rank and sex you know that this this
idea that would keep
an exalted freedom alive even even in
servitude itself that is gone
that that actually is gone and it's too
bad
last night we were at the ryman we did a
backstage live show it was a ton of fun
thanks to everyone who came out we had a
really really great time
and someone asked what's the surest sign
that civilization is on the decline and
the question was not to me it was to
someone else and we were trying to move
quickly through these questions but it
seems to me the answer is
when
men stop holding the door whether it's
the door to a building or the door to a
car you know or men's not picking up the
tab or
when men stop treating women with a
special sort of respect and vice versa
for that matter
and the reason for this is
that these are the
ornamentations of life
that represent an entire developed
sophisticated serious
social system
right and that kind of care is gone
there is something i didn't even start
doing this until at least in my 20s
uh
there's something nice about a man
opening up the car door for a woman it
will delay you all right when you when
you've got to get out of the house you
got to go somewhere that's you and your
wife or you and your girlfriend or you
and whoever just some chick and you're
walking if you just each walk to your
own door and just get in quickly and
turn the car on you'll get you'll leave
faster
but there's something less dignified
there's something a little utilitarian a
little a little savage
if if you'll allow me that perhaps
hyperbole about that sort of thing take
the minute take the time
take the time for these these
little ornamentations that that make
life a little bit more civilized you
know when we when we sit down to eat
dinner
we can either sit down put our napkin on
our lap say grace
you know look look greet everybody pour
wine make sure everyone has their own
food then pick up our knife and fork and
start eating our food or we can just
like shove our faces in our slot buckets
and not do not do any of those things
and i guess it would be faster and more
efficient and utilitarian to do it in
the latter way but it would not be
civilized it would not be civil and
that's that's what it's very sad to see
this from british airways because i
think we in america always think of the
brits as being a little more
sophisticated than we are but their
priorities are now out of order and it's
not just on the man woman thing on the
airplane they're out of order even with
regard to the species
so the british medical journal
has come as a very respected medical
journal they have come out with an
editorial
suggesting
that doctors need to cut treatment well
i should say doctors and the public
health bureaucrats in who at least in
the united kingdom are controlling the
the health care system in america
we still have a little bit more of a
free market system but it's it's
probably heading in the british
direction
so they say we need to cut health care
to people
in order to save the planet
so you've got to stop providing medical
care to human beings
so that
a rock hurtling through space
can
be happier i don't know the rock doesn't
have emotions but somehow out of care
for the rock hurtling through space we
need to allow more people to die here's
from the editorial quote
care contributes four to five percent of
global greenhouse gas emissions in the
national health service in the uk
62
of these emissions are from its supply
chains and 24
from delivery of health care health
professionals can be institutional
leaders who drive decarbonization in
hospitals through reducing over
diagnosis and over treatment in health
care pause for a second what is
what is over diagnosis you know
presumably something is being diagnosed
and that's a real health care problem so
if it's being over diagnosed you're
saying that too many people are having
their their health problems uh properly
diagnosed anyway it goes on eliminating
waste streamlining services and better
managing suppliers and procurement all
of these efforts will bring us closer to
making health care more sustainable
okay so that that that's a little weird
to me to see that that okay four to five
percent of carbon dioxide
coming out is from the health care
system so let's you know that thing that
keeps the people alive and healthy so
let's stop that
let's let's stop doing that and that way
there will be a little less carbon
dioxide in the air or something and that
because that somehow that's the sun that
is leading the sun monster to kill us or
i don't know that's at least what they
say
there's a separate piece in the british
medical journal beyond this broad
editorial this is a separate piece by an
author named ramia matthew who goes even
further who says that we we shouldn't
even really diagnose and treat cancer
because you know we do it earlier and
earlier well i'll just put it in his own
words he writes the pressure to diagnose
cancers earlier and earlier is another
major contributor to modern medicine's
carbon footprint over successive years
we've been told to continually lower our
threshold for suspecting cancer and
we've encouraged we are encouraged to
investigate sooner and more extensively
in primary care most patients with
mildly elevated or even high normal
platelet counts now undergo a barrage of
investigations in case thrombocytosis
is an early indicator
of underlying cancer
what does the yield of these tests have
to be like to make this an acceptable
approach and shouldn't we be considering
the environmental impact of putting so
many patients on a conveyor belt of
investigations as part of cost-benefit
analysis acosta what on earth are you
talking about man
man this guy has lost the threat ma'am
the british medical journal has lost the
threat you're saying
how
how much are we willing to offend mother
gaia you know the the the earth nature
god this new pagan idea that we live for
the benefit of our deity this rock how
much are we willing to offend the pagan
deity of the earth
while we diagnose cancer in people how
many
let's flip the question
how many cancer patients should die
to appease the nature gods
how many how many cancer patients is
remia matthew and the british medical
journal willing to sacrifice to the
nature gods so that the sun monster
doesn't kill us at some point in the
future
my answer would be zero i don't like
sacrificing people to the pagan gods i'm
not afraid of the sun monster in
particular and i'm i'm certainly less
concerned about the feelings and health
of a rock than i am about human beings
because i think human beings have
dignity and i think they are elevated
above creation the rest of the creation
and i think that actually amer america
that human beings have dominion over the
creation and that we ought to be good
stewards of that but we ought not to
sacrifice ourselves for
the rocks and the plants and the birds
and the fish
that's the that's the christian view
that's the view of our civilization
until about five minutes ago but as
christianity has
has fallen apart as as a political force
it obviously can't fall apart generally
but as a political force in the west it
has fallen apart what has happened the
same old crazy kooky pagan ideas have
crept back in
afterward and you're seeing that even in
what used to be
a
high point of civilization
the united kingdom
talk about the tale wagging the dog if
you did not catch backstage last night
then you missed
oh you me look you missed a lot of talk
about politics and you you missed a lot
of talk about whatever a lot of exciting
announcements we're making about
entertainment but most importantly you
missed smokey mike and the god king you
missed a very very important uh
performance by
your favorite 1960s rock band so that's
a huge mistake even worse though it
means you didn't hear this exciting news
we've got a lot of new projects in the
works that are going to change the way
you stream like our new comedy series
that we're bringing you featuring none
other than the hilarious adam corolla
plus our new movie starring the fearless
gina carano terror on the prairie which
is currently in production in montana
last but certainly not least
we're dropping the teaser trailer for
shut-in our first original production
it's a 60-second look into a thriller
that you are not going to want to miss
we cannot wait to share these final
products with you so keep your ears and
eyes peeled for updates on their release
dates also a little bit of news this
news broke
last night
while i was
on stage at the ryman but uh the
university of wisconsin madison is
messing around with my my tour with
senator ted cruz so there's been a
change of venue i'm flying out there
immediately after this show more on more
on that in just a minute first head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe we'll be
right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show
last night when we took the stage at the
ryman there was there was a chant heard
above all of the other chants three
words
you guessed them let's go brandon
rang out from the moment the curtain
opened up on stage
and this is not just happening in
tennessee and it's not just happening in
the united states it's happening all
over the world the the revolt against
joe biden through the euphemism the
euphemistic
kind of in-joke chant let's go brandon
has now hit the streets of rome
[Music]
joe biden
so i guess the italians have not gotten
the message that the way that we do that
chant here is we say let's go brandon
you know but it's confusing because then
you got to translate from english to
more english to mimi english to
into italian it's very very confusing
it doesn't sound as good in italian
why why are they doing this in rome
and elsewhere too i mean you're seeing
similar kind of protests around the
world why
joe biden is ostensibly at least the
president of the united states he's not
the leader of italy he's not the leader
of the european union he's not the head
of the united nations so why why
are you seeing these protests well i
think we need to
recognize the united states is the
leader of
the world at the very least the leader
of the west
and
at least until very recently certainly
the leader of the rest of the world and
if you've ever traveled outside of the
country especially if you've ever
traveled outside the country during an
american election season
you will notice the degree to which the
rest of the world
looks to the united states for
leadership and they are invested in the
outcome of the american election and and
america
is really is sort of an empire at least
with a lot of soft power and that power
is projected everywhere in the world i
remember i was traveling in the middle
east during the 2016 right before the
2016 election really kicked into high
gear it was already
really up and going and i was in beirut
i was in the united arab emirates i was
in dubai and abu dhabi and i was down in
muscat oman i was in india and anywhere
i went anywhere and everywhere i went
people were talking about the american
election it was it was i thought it was
so strange i thought what do you people
care oh right the united states is the
leader of the world so they are very
invested in that and i think these f joe
biden chants and let's go brand enchants
happening elsewhere in the world
they represent broadly
the power of the people
versus the ruling class and the reason
i think this has caught on the f joe
biden thing and the
let's go brandon thing is because it's a
meme
okay it expresses a real thing i really
believe that uh
brandon ought to go
and you know but but it's also a meme
and memes
are in themselves a representation of
the power of the people in 2016
sometimes you would see trump supporters
refer to meme magic this idea that
you've got the ruling class here
that controls all of the media that
controls all of the big tech platforms
that controls the administrative state
that controls much if not most of the
elected government that controls the
universities and the schools and
everything just controls everything
and then you've got some memes
you know and then you've got these
people who are just posting little memes
on the internet making fun of the ruling
class and getting their message across
because the emperor has no clothes there
there was a meme that came out after the
election
and it showed
uh two different groups it showed one it
was like the new york times building and
it said
the title was who do you think would win
in a fight now in the new york times
building says the entire globalist
neo-liberal media corporate
establishment or and then it had a
picture of alex jones the radio host or
a shirtless vitamin salesman
and and jones won because jones was the
trump supporter he was being identified
there with trump and obviously the times
and all the rest of them were identified
with hillary so i i think a lot of this
has to do with people saying look all of
the official power
almost all of it in the entire world
rests with the liberal establishment but
we still have power and how are we going
to express it we're going to march
through even the streets of rome and
chant
let's go brandon or some variation
thereof
now you are seeing a pushback against
this this ugly rule of of the oligarchic
powers that really expanded during covid
during covet was really when the
technocrats and the bureaucrats and the
oligarchs came up and said hey we're
going to suspend all of your normal life
all of the normal rule of law and
force you in your homes force you out of
your job shut down your church force you
to muzzle yourself make you take some
experimental drug for a virus that's not
particularly dangerous to most people
and they just kept changing
uh their their minds by the day and
further and further encroaching on
people's freedoms and way of life
so
there has been some pushback but it's
been
slow
maybe you get a republican governor who
says okay we're going to not require
masks well that's good but other people
are requiring this okay we're going to
the government is prohibited from
mandating masks okay what about the
private businesses what about my place
of work well i don't know it's maybe and
so increasingly we're not going to
mandate vaccines but corporations might
vanda vaccines right and it's been this
real battle the whole time well governor
greg abbott down in texas
doing a great great job and he just had
a very important
uh order come out governor greg abbott
is banning
any entity in texas from instituting a
vaccine mandate this is very important
you might remember that a little while
ago governor abbott banned the
government from instituting them so the
state government could not have a
vaccine mandate but that still left most
texans out in the cold because the most
texans don't work for the state
government so now he is completely
banning here's here's the exact wording
quote no entity in texas can compel
receipt of a covid19 vaccine by any
individual including an employee or a
consumer who objects to such vaccination
for any reason of personal conscience
based on a religious belief or for
medical reasons including prior recovery
from covet 19 i hereby suspend all
relevant statutes to the extent
necessary to enforce this prohibition
this is great i love this extremely cool
very conservative
right
just it also shows us the difference
between the libertarian point of view
and the conservative point of view
during a lot of the later 20th century
the libertarian and the conservative
point of view were identified as being
identical and the libertarian point of
view really dominated that
now i think we're seeing the split a
little bit more and so the libertarian
and you're seeing a lot of
neoconservatives and
libertarian types objecting to governor
abbott's
decision here and they're saying this is
an affront to liberty well how is it an
affront to liberty to say you're not
gonna have a vaccine mandate well they
argue because
the private business should have the
right to mandate vaccines
so the government should not infringe on
your individual rights but the private
businesses should infringe on your
individual rights and that's the
greatest defense of liberty
now
the libertarian argument here i think is
is just just silly
it's like it's like another meme of
someone you know
of a of that little snake from the
gadsden flag having his head crushed by
a big boot and it's got all the names of
corporations on the boot and the little
snake is saying
at least it's not the government well no
if my way of life if my traditions if my
liberties are being taken away by some
woke corporation
that is no better to me than if the
government is taking them away in many
cases it's worse because i have even
less control over the corporation than i
do over the government
so what abbott is is doing
is saying no we are not just going to
get political power as conservatives and
then not use it and let vote
corporations do whatever they want
we as conservatives are going to win
political power and then wield the
political power to affect our political
vision there was a big debate that came
up last night on backstage and it was a
debate over secession should
texas for instance leave the united
states should the the right-wing states
secede or vice versa should the should
the democrat states deceive or should we
encourage that or should we permit that
and it was a big divide me
it wasn't usual you know i agree with
candace owens on
almost everything and uh matt walsh and
i often agree on a lot of things but on
this one they were both calling for a
succession and i was more in line with
what drew
ben and jeremy were saying namely i
first of all secession is going to
involve a civil war and i don't think we
ought to clamor at least for if a war
comes i guess we have to deal with it
but i don't think we should be clamoring
for it but furthermore it just seems to
me that although there are many stalwart
strong tough conservatives like my
friends who were on stage last night who
who are more open to the idea of a texan
or a cal exit or a secession i actually
think it's kind of the lib answer here
meaning
why would i allow half of my country
just to go away and become a lib
dystopia and kill a zillion babies and
you know wave the
rainbow flag of the am of the liberal
empire and
and rend my country in two why would i
do that when the alternative is
just winning back political power in my
own country and
and prohibiting the left from pursuing
their radical destructive agenda why
can't we just stop them
right there
the secession argument seems to me to be
a little bit of a you do you kind of
argument well okay i have no right to
tell people in in california that they
can't mutilate children's genitals and
kill babies and do all sorts of great
yes i do i absolutely do have that right
as an american and i damn well intend to
use that right and i think we all ought
to do that well it's if if people want
to teach critical race theory in schools
in new york you can have no right to
talk about that if they want to burn the
american flag in some god forsaken
left-wing state then that's their right
i don't think it's their right i don't
think they have the right to do that and
if they do happen to have the right
today i think we ought to take that
right away because i don't think that's
a good right
at all to permit in this country and i
think it'll lead to national destruction
and i don't think great nations
continue to grow and flourish
by dividing themselves into ever smaller
bits absolutely
not no way you know we're seeing this
speech issue happening right now
and it relates to covid i am flying out
moments after i wrap this show today to
wisconsin with my friend ted cruz and
we're going to be doing a verdict live
show in conjunction with young america's
foundation at the university of
wisconsin-madison this is a very
left-wing school
and we had a feeling that there would be
some shenanigans and there are
the school is demanding that we mask for
the event now i'm not just saying
they're demanding that the audience
masks i hate that to begin with and i
think that people should
basically just avoid that stupid mandate
altogether
but no no they wanted me
and cruz
to mask
on stage during the event
so we're going to be on stage on camera
they're saying
and and that's going to be the event and
so
in many in recent years there have been
many attempts to stifle conservative
speech on campus in this case they'd
just be basically taping our mouths shut
so we said well you can't expect the
speakers
certainly not the speakers to muzzle
themselves they said no that's the rule
and so you look and there is a rule
now there's an exemption for education
related arts performances it would seem
to me that a very popular podcast with a
sitting u.s senator would count as such
but uw-madison doesn't want to
do that because they they hate our show
and they hate conservatives being able
to speak and so they they just want to
shut us up they've given exemptions to
liberal speeches but they don't want to
give an exemption to ours so the the
libertarian point of view i think would
be well okay what can we do it's you
madison let them do whatever they want
my conservative point of view is uh-uh
no way we're gonna figure out a
workaround for this speech today but in
the future i think what we need to do is
go in take political power back fire
these administrators
change the rules and and
transform that culture and transform
that institution back towards something
resembling a coherent good american
educational institution
more people have died from coronavirus
in 2021 than died in 2020. you might see
some conservatives mentioning this
on twitter you're certainly not going to
see this from the establishment media
but why does it matter
you know i've always thought that the
death statistics
that are have been seriously manipulated
from the very beginning of the epidemic
to the point that
anyone who died with kovid was counted
as dying of kovid you know the median
and average age of a coveted death in
the united states have been north of 80
from the beginning
and they've been higher than the average
life expectancy in the united states but
we're never allowed to take that into
account or suggest that that might tell
us something about the meaning of these
numbers
we even saw in some cases people who
died in a car wreck if they died with
the coronavirus it was called a covet
death someone could get shot in the head
and then if they died with
coronavirus then they were counted as a
covid death and you had public health
officials telling us that but
because there was a political incentive
to inflate these numbers
that's that's the way the statistics
were counted
so i thought i don't know why why are
now we
playing this silly statistics game where
we're trying to make arguments from
really arguments about justice the
justice of forced vaccinations the
justice about the mass mandates justice
about all of this from just these narrow
kind of statistics well there is one
reason that this these numbers matter
it shows you the double standard and it
shows you how from the beginning there
was never going to be any way
to argue from the science
to convince these people to stop their
their madness
when people were dying under trump under
the trump administration
when people were dying of covid notably
in democrat states california did very
poorly on the virus and new york did the
worst of all on the virus new jersey did
pretty bad too
that was trump's fault when andy cuomo
was sending sick people into nursing
homes and killing elderly new yorkers
needlessly by the thousands that was
trump's fault all of the covey deaths
were trump's fault but now that people
are dying ostensibly of covet on joe
biden's watch
whose fault is it
ron desantis
of course greg abbott
of course
it's r it's the republican governors how
come it wasn't the democrat governor's
fault when they were dying in democrat
states often under trump how come that
was the president's fault then but now
it's not the president's fault it's the
governor's fault because
there is no logic to this
because this is not about the science or
even about a coherent political
philosophy this is about
using
and exploiting
a virus
to attain new political powers and to
wield them ruthlessly against the left's
opponents that's what it's about that's
what it's been about from the very
beginning
and so i don't want to toot my own horn
you know how much i hate to say i told
you so but from from
if not day one at least day two and
really i think from day one of this
epidemic i came out and said guys don't
give in don't give in on this stuff this
isn't seems really overblown this seems
opportunistic and cynical
well a number of other people not just
the rock-ribbed right-wingers working in
politics but a lot of other people
called this out as well
including eric clapton
you know eric clapton one of the great
popular musicians of the last 50 years
eric clapton
is not exactly i don't know he's not
like a
maga hat wearing rock ribbed
conservative he's he's expressed some
conservative views over the years but he
said he's also a rock musician he's
expressed some kind of liberal views
so
eric clapton
went out and got the vaccine he got the
covid vaccine he was encouraged to do it
i guess he's a little slightly long in
the tooth these days you know he's not
as young as he once was so he goes
gets the vaccine and he has an adverse
reaction to it
and it causes him some nerve problems he
already had a nerve issue but it causes
him some more nerve problems and he says
oh my and he's talking to his doctors
and they said yeah well you know this
does happen sometimes and and he
couldn't play guitar for some period of
time several weeks at least and so now
he's he's really campaigning against
vaccine mandates he's saying he won't
play at venues that require the vaccines
and so i think this is really admirable
i tweeted out and i said you know
whatever you think of clapton the man's
got more credibility than dr fauci so i
got a call from rolling stone magazine
it doesn't happen a lot usually the
magazines that call for interviews
rolling stone is not one of them and
they're really angry clapped in the
headline is eric clapton isn't just
spouting vaccine nonsense he's
bankrolling it i do have to thank the
author of this piece because he
he quoted me i think pretty faithfully
he actually did express
my views on this but
it's amazing that
rolling stone needed some right winger
to tell them this which is
since when
our rock and roll star is supposed to
just
go along with the establishment party
line
when did that happen
isn't that kind of weird
i'm not even saying i love rock and roll
you know i don't i do not think it's the
highest form of art even though i guess
i'm technically in a rock band from like
you know sort of 1960s rock band but i
don't think it's the highest form of art
okay but
rolling stone does and a lot of people
do in our culture a lot of people love
rock and roll and rock and roll was all
about flicking a middle finger to
established authority and breaking rules
and being subversive except now you'll
notice
all of it just about
goes along with the party line now part
of this is because the radicals of the
1960s became the establishment and they
had lots of bad ideas and they've done a
very bad job with society and that's why
you're seeing society crumble all around
you
but those rockers are part of that
establishment and very few of them some
exceptions
eric clapton van morrison also has been
pretty strong against these vaccine
mandates they've come out and said no
actually i don't think we should just
give all our political rights and
freedoms to dr vauchy no this seems kind
of wrong actually no i'm going to trust
my audience to make their own medical
decisions like we used to do in this
civilization no i'm actually gonna
i'm gonna trust
my own
listeners to make some basic decisions
about their own lives
that that is
i think the greatest evidence of all
that
our ruling class our ruling elite our
ruling establishment has
has transformed radically and so if we
are going to undo that i don't think we
need to grow our hair out or get a you
know get a ton of like rock tattoos or
anything like that should do a bunch of
drugs probably
we shouldn't do any of those things but
what we are going to have to do is
question that ruling establishment we're
going to have to subvert it in creative
ways and we're going to have to take a
very long path just like it did for the
radicals of the 60s a years decades long
path to gradually but steadily attain
political power and wield it and have
the courage to wield it i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see up in wisconsin tonight i'll see you
back here tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show